hello games has announced that a new
patch is coming to the playstation 4
version of no man's sky this week the
developer said on Twitter that when it's
released it'll mean that around ninety
percent of the games crash issues will
have been resolved I'm Lucy and this is
your procedurally-generated gamespot
news update our game said that this new
patch version 1.0 six is currently in
testing and assured you'll to come out
this week though they didn't specify a
release date as part of hello games
effort to fix all crash scenarios on ps4
we can expect further patches to the
developer said that we obviously won't
stop until these issues are 100-percent
resolved also these patches contain
other fixes and improvements to hello
games also shared some details on how
crash reporting works for no man's sky
every time the game crashes a report is
sent to hello games since the game's
launch on August ninth the studio has
been collecting these and categorizing
them in order of priority they said this
has been incredibly useful and allows us
to know exactly how many people are
affected hello games has updates the ps4
version of no man's sky at least two
other times since launch to fix the
crashing problems the pc version of no
man's sky hasn't been without its issues
either including things like performance
and bring Roy problems in addition to
crashes hello games has patched that
version a number of times since its
release on August twelfth and of course
more updates are on the way so what did
you make of no man's sky are you a fan
or were you disappointed let me know in
the comments below or come find me on
Twitter I met Lucy James games and for
more on no man's sky make sure you keep
a gamespot
you